foreign
JW is with us JW is uh in Atlanta hijw
how are you
hey Dave just fine how about y'all
better than we deserve how can we help
so me and my wife are having the issue
right now uh
we got to JW we got you
I'm about twenty thousand dollars from
having the house paid off excellent
but
now she wants me to sell the house and
buy more expensive house
I can taste it
I'm almost there
I'm so close
and I I don't know if you know I talked
to her and was why why is it that we
need a more expensive house and because
that's what everybody else does
and I'm like well I don't want to take
out another loan it's so close to having
it paid off and you know she said well
that's what everybody else does we just
you know you just suck it up that's what
everybody else does and I want to be
like everybody else
and I can't understand I can't figure
out how to convince her to
let's just pay this one off so you've
drug you've drug her Kicking and
Screaming into debt free
yeah
and she's gonna try to drag you kicking
and screaming into 3 500 more square
feet
oh my God
all right here's what I guarantee you
haven't done yet JW you ready
yep I guarantee you haven't sat down
with her
and said uh honey
I'm exhausted
and I'm scared
I'm scared that when I owe money when we
owe a mortgage if something happens to
me that I'm not gonna be able to take
care of you and the kids
yeah yeah absolutely but hold on but
most of us knuckleheaded guys try to
attack this your wife's question with uh
with a math with a math answer
I want you to approach this with a hard
answer for probably the first time with
your heart
okay I'm scared I'm exhausted I need
some time I'm not interested in being
like everybody else I'm interested in
you and me building something magical
that's ours
and maybe that's a bigger house someday
I can't
borrow more money right now
actually yeah yeah okay
but you got you gotta you gotta connect
with her there man because otherwise
it's going to be a tug of war game she
feels like you won the first match and
she is she going she's gonna win the
second match you know we've got to
change the uh position from daddy
daughter to husband wife
daddy daddy own a bigger house Daddy
give me a bigger house Daddy
everybody else gets one Daddy
instead instead it's like you and me are
a team
how can we
have the life that we want to build not
other people want to build but the life
that we want to build that includes an
amazing future and us making our
decisions together you get a vote and I
get a vote
not I'm denying you what you want
because I'm a mean old husband that's a
daddy daughter thing
you're not you're not her daddy
and um yeah absolutely yeah and so you
know that that and that happens in every
marriage uh some more than others some
function all the time that way some
function uh for 20 seconds that way
occasionally or it flips and yeah or it
flips Mom some little boy's got a little
boy's got a mommy taking care of him she
does all the bills and he just works he
doesn't have to think about anything he
just brings in the money and I do all
the adult stuff and uh oh God creepy and
so um yeah that happens all the time
though and so uh
you don't have much of that here but
what John's telling you is come
alongside her and then just pour your
heart out and say this has been a goal
in my life for the first time in my life
I'm free
I can breathe and you're asking me to
let a 300 pound man stand on my chest
again
I just I can't do it
I can't do it and I do want to give you
what you want I want us to have things
that we like together but I also but I
want to do it like grown-ups and so
let's start talking about
getting a bigger house and how we can
get the money together to do that with
cash and might take three years instead
of three months
but the chances of me going into debt
again are precisely zero I'm not doing
it
and um uh I mean Sharon's pretty
acquainted with that conversation I
don't borrow money
for anyone for any reason
ever again I'm through I had my I had my
run with that